your new 123 plus recycling and refuse
collection service starts on the 1st of
august 2022
operating across south warwickshire the
new service will see food waste
collected weekly in a food caddy
recycling collected fortnightly in a
blue lidded wheel bin refuse collected
three weekly in your existing gray pin
and garden waste collected fortnightly
in your existing green bin
food waste is the most hazardous type of
household waste which is why we're
collecting all food waste including
bones peelings scraps and all every week
in a new food caddy
you'll receive two caddies one to use
inside the house and one you'll put
outside each week to be emptied
you can position the smaller caddy
inside your kitchen where you can easily
access it
the caddy can be lined with newspaper or
a compostable bag or you can just put it
in loose
simply put all your food waste in this
caddy then when it's full empty it into
your outside caddy
[Music]
the outside caddy has a lockable lid
that prevents it from being tampered
with by pests
place it at the front of your property
on the day of your collection with the
lid firmly closed
the blue lidded wheel bin will enable
you to put all of your recycling into
one bin including tetrapak cartons and
black plastics like meat trays and fruit
containers a full list of what you can
put in your recycling bin will be
provided to you
if you have extra recycling then you can
place this next to your bin in a rigid
container a cardboard box or residence
in warwick district can reuse their
existing red box you'll also be able to
recycle textiles in a separate sealed
bag small electrical items that can fit
into a carrier bag and household
batteries also in a separate sealed bag
such as a sandwich bag or an old bread
bag
you can place these out for collection
on any week of your collection next to
your blue lidded recycling bin grey
waste bin or green garden waste bin
your gray bin should be used for any
household items that can't be recycled
at the roadside such as soft plastics or
polystyrene
if you wish to have your garden waste
collected you will need to sign up to
our garden waste subscription service
for warwick district residents this
service starts on the 1st of august
applications can be made on the
council's website you'll receive a
permit through the post that you need to
place on your bin
you can use your existing green bin and
this subscription service can be used to
recycle garden waste such as grass
cuttings branches leaves and hedge
cuttings
[Music]
alternatively you may wish to pursue
home composting and information about
this is available at www
dot
warwickshare.gov dot uk
forward slash composting
[Music]
you